i was
president of columbia pictures years ago
and frank
brought me the rights to lance's book
it's not about the bike to make as a
narrative film with matt damon attached
and we set about developing
that version of the movie we never made
it for a bunch of reasons
um
and then when
the comeback was announced
frank and i got together and thought you
know because we've been trying for so
long to make this movie and we were in
awe of this guy lance
we thought you know what this is a great
documentary let's forget that other
thing that we were trying to do let's
chronicle a year in the life of this guy
and about his return when he was old it
was about cancer and all these things
that we thought it was about and so we
said who who's the best documentary
filmmaker that we know and
alex was on top
you know right at the top of that list
and we called a meeting and he came out
and met with us i had done um a 30 for
30 for espn and alex had also done one
and i had met him sort of on the road
when we did it together and i knew that
he was a sports fan
and
um we we called him and we said you know
what do you think and he
the the thing we really liked was he was
a sports fan but it didn't know anything
about cycling so we want to get a
broader approach to the movie not it
wasn't an inside baseball kind of
story we wanted a broader approach who
is this guy we also knew that he
liked to delve into the real characters
alex is a tremendous researcher
absolutely completely thorough and he
was really initially fascinated by
lance's will
what what made this guy tick why did he
want to come back as he says in the
movie 30 by 30 for those of you that
don't know is a television series for
espn where
noted documentary filmmakers have made
sports oriented type films just and
non-documentary filmmakers i mean that's
sort of what's interesting about it
excuse me not necessarily documentary
filmmakers people who have a passion for
a certain moment people like you who
aren't really like me
we're definitely definitely we're not
there was a lot in that movie about
doping you know it wasn't as though alex
made just a you know a love letter to
lance armstrong that was a movie that
was very much about him and the
inspiration of the comeback but there
were
very sort of provocative
um interviews and and and uh
implications in the movie now just talk
about that for a moment was that a
feature film also designed to go out
into theaters absolutely yes it started
as a feature
and it was finished future documentary
yes one of the things we learned
uh
in all of this is
if you see alex gibney coming up the
steps to your house don't let him in
whatever secret you're hiding
well i don't know i might think a little
differently about that as a lady maybe
you would have a secret as a lady but
not not with his camera and not with a
camera if he has a camera because what
was interesting is he was asking all
these questions to himself but no one
would go on the record no one
not only was lance lying to us all of
2009 everybody else was that was
protecting him all of the other writers
you even see frankie in the interview
when he asked him about 1999 he says i'm
not going to talk about even the frankie
who is the one he has
really wronged in many ways yeah but
that was too you have to remember that
was 2009 and none of this stuff had come
out the usada report hadn't come out so
what frankie was being asked at that
moment was
a big deal and he just couldn't to break
that code he couldn't correct the code
was still there but if you watch you
know there's an interview if you
remember in the beginning of the movie
not an interview but a scene that would
that we shot and it's lance and his
lawyer and johann brunell it's his the
the inner circle of his
advisors and they're all talking about
whether or not he's going to be allowed
into the tour de france it's a
fascinating moment because and it's it's
very much what it was like to be around
them um
nobody talked the conversation wasn't
did he dope
it was was he ever caught
that was always the dialogue i mean
there was always noise in the air but
there was never anyone saying well dude
did you ever actually
absolutely not that was no it was off
the table it was just a lot of
conversation about i've never been
busted and that person said i was and i
wasn't and that test that but
nobody ever it never it never came down
to a confrontation
and you know the truth is frank and i
we've said this
we were in that bubble it was very
intoxicating i mean when you were around
him he's a huge personality
and his story was so fantastic
that when you were close to it or even
not that close to it you just kind of
wanted to believe in it yeah it's not
really a story about doping
it's a story about as we say a story
about power it's a story about a person
it's a story about
hubris
it's the anatomy of a lie it's
how this how is this possible for all of
these years for all of these people all
of these sponsors nike oakley you name
it two have gone on this ride
and that's i think what the interesting
thing about the movie is and and coming
away from that do you think it's the
power of one individual then that that
has that so much of that in him well he
was a rock star i mean his story was
incredible it was a perfect story i mean
you can't invent a story like that so it
was the perfect he has the perfect
personality to be out to to be the
person to be the lead in that story it
was just his bravado and his arrogance
and hubris all of it it was it was sort
of the perfect storm it's not a cycling
movie either i think that you know one
of the things that's been interesting
the audience is the people that have
come out
may never have gone to a bike race that
was always the case with lance also
there were all these people who were
suddenly like my mom was watching the
tour de france she didn't care about
bike racing but this guy was so
captivating
you had to completely re-edit the film
yeah um so how much material in this was
approximately from the original piece
and how much did you put in to have to
reshoot and go back
i say there's there's only about 35
of the original movie really yeah yeah
and a lot of it was you know the bike
racing a lot of the tour a lot of that
footage obviously uh was in it we have a
great other movie the story which i love
about this
making a documentary other than my day
job where there's i know what's going to
happen every day you never know so the
story about lance trying to win
his eighth title
um
turned into something very interesting
he wasn't going to win and he was going
to fight to stay on the podium that was
a whole new story that was fantastic too
and then when
matt and i flew to austin a little over
a year ago and
lance confessed to us in person it was
the most surreal night of our lives
amazing moment he hadn't talked to
anybody
way before oprah felt compelled to come
clean to us and we got on plane the next
day flew to new york met with alex and
went to sony classics and said we have
another movie will you back us and
michael and tom
did yeah and the fascinating thing for
us was when we then
looked at the first movie
everything that was in it and a lot of
interviews that weren't in it
when you look at them in the new light
meant something completely different and
that was fascinating
and because once we knew for sure
everything was different ferrari for
example i hadn't seen it really
interesting he always looked like he
swallowed a canary to me
but
but now we knew
he was trying to tell us the story
i think the other thing that that we've
been asked
in the last couple of weeks is why did
lance let you do this
well i think it was because
he thought he was going to race clean so
why not let them in there's nothing to
hide
i think that's 98 true i have this weird
theory
um that most of it was hubris most of it
is is what frank's saying which is
bring bring me your most bring it on
yeah your greatest journalist whatever i
can a lie to him although anybody
and you said it
it's alex gibney and lance
did his homework
you know when we said we wanted to hire
alex it always does they they looked at
all the movies and we weren't asking
permission but we said this is our guy
and they did like a little alex gibney
very smart i mean they're yeah they're
very easy yeah they've got this far
seriously and don't forget this is this
story that he's been protecting with
everything he has so they're not going
to suddenly flippantly let some guy in
they really checked out alex gibney
and they said yes
like you know he could have said well
you can't come into my house you can't
i'm not gonna but he said sure
there's a little part of me
that thinks
he might have just wanted somebody to
like
blow the doors off this thing that very
unconsciously
deep down
um
it was alex give me and of course it was
going to come out we've been doing a lot
of therapy in the last two weeks frank
and i
it's been very nice this is where we've
gotten to
you know the oprah interview was like
okay i'm going to go on there i'm going
to say what i need to say and it'll be
fine right it'll go away they'll forgive
you and
yeah that couldn't be further from what
that was the other incredible moment was
being there for that three hours
in the room next door with his lawyers
and his pr people and all of his inner
circle
just watching this
amazing thing yeah